les images de cette visite de Marion
maréchal la députée du vauluse lors de
la rencontre avec les veilleurs à
Versailles l'actualité locale cette
semaine c'est aussi cette femme blessée
par balle attrape en pleine rue
l'enquête se poursuit et puis nous
parlerons aussi des rythmes scolaires
qui font toujours débat le manque de
moyens pouritpousser des commune à une
nouvelle organisation au mois de
septembre retour aussi dans ce journal
sur le Festival de Cannes depuis le
début de la semaine en partenariat avec
Radio sensation nous vous proposons de
suivre les ivelinois sur place
réalisateurs exploitant et également les
jeunes particip aux rencontres junior le
festival junior de
Cann les militants du Parti socialiste
ont tranché hier soir se déroul le vote
pour les motions ces fameux textes censé
donner la ligne de conduite de la
formation pour les prochaines années les
chiffres ne sont que partiels au moment
où nous enregistrons ce journal mais la
proposition portée par le premier
secrétaire Jean-Christophe cambadellis
obtiendrait un score supérieur à 60 % au
niveau national pour la motion B celle
des frondurs ce serait plutôt aux
alentours de 30 % pour l'ancien ministre
o amont député desvelin qui soutenait ce
texte c'est malgré tout une belle
avancée politique toujours cette semaine
était invité dans ce journal Eddie hat
le conseiller régional d'Île-de-France
du Parti radical gauche il siège au sein
de la majorité socialiste de Jean-Paul
hon il est revenu sur l'éviction de ce
dernier pour la prochaine campagne
électorale au profit du président de
l'Assemblée nationale Claude Bartolone
il a également évoqué l'idée d' une
possible union et ce dès le premier tour
pour l'instant ce sont essentiellement
des affaires internes au partis soci
ce qui doit prévaloir maintenant c'est
le rassemblement de la gauche parce
qu'il nous faut conserver cette région à
gauche on a des raisons de craindre si
Madame pcrè prenait la présidence de
cette région donc je dirais je n'ai pas
d'appréciation personnelle à App porter
si ce n'est que le bilan aujourd'hui de
cette de ces 17 années de région à
gauche sont aussi le résultat de
l'exercice politique d'un homme fort qui
était jean-pauluchon et d'un bilan d'une
majorité de gauche rassemblé autour de
lui autour des objectifs politiques que
nous nous étions fixés donc c'est à
mettre à son crédit maintenant votre
volonté vous personnellement c'est
d'être présent sur cette liste dès le
premier tour moi j'ai la volonté de
repartir aux élections régionales pour
poursuivre le travail engagé maintenant
les conditions du rassemblement le Parti
socialiste si nous devons nous allier à
ce dernier euh il doit les créer il doit
favoriser le rassemblement nous nous
attendons qu'une fois Claude Bartelone a
investi officiellement à partir du 28
mai que des contacts soient pris c'est à
lui de prendre contact avec ses
partenaires de gauche euh le
rassemblement oui au service des
franiliens bien sûr et avec l'ensemble
des composantes et notamment le Parti
radical de gauche hier soir s'est tenu à
Versailles le 2e anniversaire des
veilleurs jeudi soir ce groupe qui
souhaite notamment que le gouvernement
revienne sur le mariage pour tous et qui
se réunit régulièrement sur la place du
marché Notre-Dame cette fois-ci ils
étaient près de 300 à avoir fait le
déplacement avec cette question
sommes-nous gouvernés par les juges leur
réponse s'est faite en chanson mais
aussi avec la lecture de témoignages de
textes de poèmes sans oublier
l'intervention de leur invité la députée
FN du vocluse Marion maréchal Le Pen
certaines décisions de justice font écho
aux lois supranationales de la Cour
européenne notamment ou la c'est la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme parfois
et souvent au détriment des actions
politiques c'estàd que les politiques
suivent les les jurisprudences les
action des tribunaux et donc ils ont une
certaine forme de pression à légiférer
pour administrer la cité al nous nous
pensons l'inverse que le politique doit
donner le L et la justice doit être un
exécutant de ces lois je suis venu
parler ce soir du gouvernement des juges
donc finalement de l'impuissance
politique dont souffre aujourd'hui la
France parce qu'elle est malheureusement
soumise à un certain nombre de de
d'institutions suprational de
juridiction suprationale qui grandent
extrêmement difficile les grandes
réformes dont aurait besoin notre pays
l'actualité de cette semaine marquée par
ses coups de feu en direction d'une
femme enceinte à trappe mardi en fin
d'après-midi cette dernière a été
blessée par balle dans le dos alors
alors qu'elle regagnait son domicile au
square Paul Verlin ses jours ne sont pas
en danger un fait d'hiver qui intervient
malgré tout alors qu'il y a 3 semaines à
peine un jeune garçon de 14 ans était
abattu en pleine rue les de faits ne
sont pas liés assurent la police
judiciaire de Versailles chargé de cette
enquête le résumé des faits c'est avec
Catherine zulato Michel midero et
William
l squir Verlin attrape mardi fin
d'après-midi les enquêteurs accompagnés
de l'équipe sinophile recherche tous les
indices qui pourrai les mettre sur la
piste du tireur à 17h une femme d'une e
d'années enceinte accompagnée de sa
fille s'écroule sur la chaussée elle
vient d'être touchée à l'omoplate par
une balle de petit calibre ses jours ne
sont pas en danger ni ceux de l'enfant
qu'elle porte la femme a été aussitôt
transportée à l'hôpital 3 semaines après
la mort de Moussa dans le quartier c'est
les mois je peur pour les enfants pour
les filles pour les parce que moi j'ai C
filles un garçon ça fait un an je suis
déménagéess je me disait que bon là
c'est c'est meilleur esoir ici et ben je
m'attendais pas à ça et et ça c'est
c'est choquant
ça m'a surpris ouais drame familial tir
volontaire balle perdu toutes les
hypothèses sont soulevé ce mardi soir à
l'issue du conseil municipal de trappe
des élus réagissaient à l'annonce de ce
nouveau fait d'hiver sur la commune il
faut le prendre évidemment très au
sérieux parce que c'est pas admissible
qu'on puisse vivre dans les rux de
trappe de tel violence une série noire
dans un contexte
où je je veux insister sur ce point euh
ce lors de ce premier trimestre attrape
tout lesffet de violence dans tout ce
qui est mesuré infraction lié au
cambriolage délinquence économique
euh violence faite aux personnes trafic
de stupéfiants les les les chiffres du
recul de la délinquence att trpe sont
tous dans des pourcentages qui sont
autour de 20 % en terme de recul
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
c'est toujours la même c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait malheureusement depuis 2
semaines 3 semaines il y a eu la marche
blanche et cetera mais rien n changé sur
le terrain les mêmes causes produiront
toujours les mêmes effets la police
municipale de trappe va toujours être
embryonnaire je rappelle qu'il a trois
fois moins policiers municipaux à Trapp
que dans les villes voisines la question
de la vidéosurveillance va rester tabou
l'enquête a été confiée à la police
judiciaire de Versailles pour leure une
certitude il n'y a pas de lien entre
cette affaire et celle qui a secoué la
ville le 1er mai dernier Moussa 14 ans
avait été tué dans une fusillade par des
hommes cagoulés le mode opératoire et le
type d'arme utilisé ne sont pas les
mêmes
vous venez de l'entendre ce fait d'hiver
intervient quelques semaines après la
mort dans cette même ville d'un
adolescent lors d'une fusillade au pied
de son immeuble Moussa au lendemain de
ce drame nous avions invité sur ce
plateau loï travers c'est le responsable
local du syndicat de police Alliance il
pointait le manque de moyens pour agir
ces dernières années écoutez il y a eu
il y a quelques temps la création et
c'est d'ailleurs en cours encore d'une
communauté d'agglomération regroupant
d'un point de vue secteur police Guy en
cour et l' en cour et trappe la
problématique et nous l'avions dénoncé à
l'époque c'est que tout ça ça s'est fait
avec sans moyens supplémentaires ni de
moyen humain supplémentairire ni
d'argent supplémentaire donc c'est un
vrai problème de ce point de vue-là on a
vu que les éléments
du il y a des des événements en début
d'année notamment l'affaire de Charlie
Hebdo qui a permis de prendre conscience
effectivement que les services de
renseignement devait être renforcé ce
qui est fait c'est très bien par contre
il ne faut pas que ça se fasse au
détriment et bien de la surveillance
générale et quelque part des effectifs
de la sécurité publique qui eux pour
l'instant ben voient leurs effectifs
baisser et plus particulièrement d'une
façon générale sur le 78 depuis 5 ans on
ne compte plus en dizaines on est en
centaines ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur traap et d'une façon générale dans
la police et nous nous nous se sont de
demander de l'appeler d'une façon très
forte c'est l'instauration d'un vrai
plan Marchal pour la sécurité ça paraît
fort comme mot c'est plein de sens mais
la réalité elle est là c'est que si on
veut des moyens effectivement humains en
en plus avec suivi de moyens financiers
et tout simplement par exemple des fois
l'attribution de véhicule en nombre tout
simplement pour faire la mission de base
qui est la sécurité générale et bien
évidemment à travers ça respecter la la
la la vision de la prévention avant de
faire quoi que ce soit de répressif mais
il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose faut
faut qu'il y ait quelque chose qui qui
déclenche sinon on va pas y arriver
autre sujet éducation le comité de suivi
des rythme scolaire toujours attrape s
réuni mardi soir pour réfléchir à une
nouvelle organisation pour la rentrer
les enseignants de la commune
s'inquiètent d'ors et déjà il
distribuent des tractes pour informer
les parents de leur mécontentement si
les horaires venaient à changer ce
serait la 3è fois en 3 ans Mélanie
poquet et LOD
moine rentrée scolaire 2014 le planning
des élèves trapiste ressemblait à ça
septembre 2015 il pourrait être à
nouveau transformé c'est ce qu'envisage
le comité de suivi des rythmes scolaires
de la commune
donc si vous voulez le scénario proposer
une alternance d'horaire selon les
écoles une école finissait à 15h le
lendemain 16h30 et comme ça on alternait
on pouvait il
pouvait utiliser les les animateurs sur
plusieurs écoles en fonction des soins
seulement ça pose énormément de
problèmes par rapport à l'enseignement
sur le plan scolaire on ne souhaite pas
que ça soit le périscolaire qui prime
sur le scolaire sur les temps
d'enseignement des élèves euh donc c'est
le scolaire qui doit passer avant tout
cette solution permettrait de réduire le
nombre d'animateurs assurant le péri
scolaire c'est un problème d'ffectif de
15h30 à 16h30 qui est au cœur de la
réforme mais cette solution entraînerait
aussi des journées de 6h pour les élèves
alors que les rythmes mis en place par
l'Éducation nationale imposent des
journées de 5h30 maximum la ville de
trappe connaîtrait alors sa troème
réforme en trois rentrées scolaires ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que c'est que on a
mis un ENF on nous a imposé un
modification de rythme bon c'était
national a priori donc voilà on
l'encaisse un petit peu même si on le
veut pas et ça se met en place de façon
très très difficile l'an dernier
finalement on arrive à trouver un
semi-équilibre cette année avec des
journées qui se ressemblent toutes
c'était déjà pas mal maternel en tous
les cas et et là ben on remet tout en
l'air on fait tout sauter parce que
manque de Rense manque de manque de
personnel qualifié manque de moyen moins
que de mais bon on parle de on parle de
moyens on parle de finan mais on parle
pas beaucoup d'enfants
l'histoire mobilisé souhaite rester aux
horaires déjà en place la mairie fixera
définitivement les conditions de la
réforme la semaine prochaine lors d'une
dernière réunion et ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer pour
l'instant le Festival de Cannes ses
films ses vedettes ses marches et son
équipe de radio sensation depuis le
début de la semaine nous retrouvons sur
place Nicolas kirilovic il nous emmène
dans les coulisses à la rencontre d'
ivelinois qui ont fait le déplacement
pour travailler se faire connaître ou
profiter des célèbres soirées canoises
je vous propose de découvrir tout
d'abord ce reportage consacré un jeune
réalisateur de plaisir qui participer au
marché du film 12000 c'est le nombre de
professionnels qui participent au marché
du film à Cann les professionnels du
cinéma du monde entier s'y retrouve pour
acheter ou vendre des films Quentin
dupui est un jeune réalisateur de 24 ans
originaire de plaisir il vient à can
pour la 3e année consécutive et
contrairement aux années précédentes il
n'a pas de film à montrer mais des
projets à financer
Quentin dupuie est un passionné de
cinéma depuis qu'il est enfant rêve
qu'il a concrétisé en faisant un BTS
audiovisuel 3 années de suite qu'il
vient au festival de can dans sa mette
un ordinateur avec ses dernières
réalisation depuis son dernier séjour
sur la Croisette Quentin n' pas ché il a
réalisé un spot contre la banalisation
de l'homophobie quce que c'est que ce
t-shirt
fa plusieurs pilotes de web se jeil
connaisseieieant manag et l'humilité
vous connaissez et un clip pour un
groupe de rock
[Musique]
alternatif can pour lui c'est THE place
to be toute la ville ve cinéma pendant
15 jours et c'est la beauté la beauté du
festival c'estàd qu'auudelà du du STR et
des paillettes des tapis rouges vraiment
tout tous les films qu'on va voir tout
se vend s'achète ce produit ici pas tous
mais c'est un des plus gros marché de
l'année un des plus gros festivals de
l'année donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui se font donc c'est ça le le
grand
et du coup Quentin enchaîne les
rencontres ce jour-là il a rendez-vous
au pavillon américain près du Palais des
Festivals d'année en année Quentin ne
cesse d'étaufer son carnet d'adresse ce
producteur réalisateur Peter moussoli
par
exemple est devenu l'un de ses amis
l'Amérique un idéal pour Quentin c'est
très business c'est très droit au but
c'est très quel est ton projet comment
tu veux le développer qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire et voilà c'est ce qui est
vraiment très ils sont très ouverts
quand ils aiment ils aiment quand ils
aiment pas ils aiment pas l'an passé
Quentin avait présenté intact au Short
Film Corner l'espace dédié au
courtmétrage l'histoire de deux
survivants face à une menace de zombie
Peter moussoli a été séduit par ce film
et il a lancé un défi à Quentin est bien
ici
non sentir vivant ça t' pas depuis
combien de
temps
je lui ai dit Quentin et si on en
faisait un long
métrage j'y vois le potentiel d'un alien
quel chose dans l'esprit des premiers
film
deot de James Camon quelque chose de
vraiment bien etintéressant mais sans
besoin d'un éorme budget du coup je lui
ai dit allez faisons un film tu as un
mois
pourécrire
AF vivent dans un monde peuplé de
zombies Quentin est donc maintenant à la
recherche de partenaires pour financer
son longmétrage n serit sur un budget
qui osilerait entre 500000 et 1 million
de dollars pour l'instant ce qui peut
paraître énorme mais ce qui est
relativement petit pour le monde du
cinéma ça reste un film indépendant ça
reste un petit budget et voilà donc on
va voir ce qui va se passer essayer de
monter de monter ce projet le mieux
possible Cann c'est la terre des
cinéphiles et une vitrine médiatique
Quentin en profite donc pour prendre des
contact et essayer de convaincre des
producteurs et des distributeurs de
l'aider à boucler son budget et ainsi
réaliser son rêve faire son premier
longmétrage le Festival de Cannes c'est
aussi l'occasion pour les exploitants de
salle de découvrir des films avant de
les programmer les directeurs des salles
des longcours et de trappe ont ainsi
fait le déplacement cette
année la folie canoise basson plein
alors installez-vous bien
confortablement car nous allons vous
faire découvrir le festival comme si
vous y étiez ici il y a ceux qui
viennent travailler faire du business
rencontrer des producteurs ou des
réalisateurs choisir les films qui sert
ensuite projetés dans leur salle ça
c'est pour la partie travail il y a ceux
aussi venus uniquement arpentter les
dance Flor de la
Croisette Luc boan est directeur du ciné
des lancour après 3 ans d'absence il
revient ici sur la Croisette et la magie
opère toujours ça c'est rigolo ce que
j'aime à Cann c'est que c'est le grand
CIRC du cinéma enfin c'est la fête du
cinéma mondial tout le monde est là la
petite exploitation la moyenne
exploitation parce que moi je je suis un
exploitant mais il y a aussi des
producteurs distrib ur tout le monde se
mélange des comédiens des gens qu'on
connaît des gens qu'on rencontre donc
c'est l'occasion à la fois de voir des
films parce que nous on vient surtout
pour travailler pour voir des films pour
pouvoir les programmer les défendre les
suivre après dans nos salles et puis
aussi rencontrer des gens des
opportunités pour monter des projets
travailler ensemble et cetera voilà
c'est ça can puis c'est la fête du
cinéma mondial une fête à laquelle il
faut s'armer de patience pour aller voir
un film il est nécessaire parfois de s'y
prendre une à 2 heures avant la
projection avec en prime une longue file
d'attente faut savoir garder sa place Al
il y a aussi des fois des incivilités
tout à l'heure dans une file d'attente
des gens qui s'insultaient pour une
place de cinéma bon c'est quand même
c'est quand même ENF voilà on vient voir
des films quoi on fait pas la guerre
donc il y a vraiment des fois des des
gens qui s'énervent qui s'excitent qui
sont prêt à tout pour passer essayer de
de gruger passer devant quelqu'un et
cetera et cetera bon tu rentres pas tu
rentres pas c'est le jeu voilà on est à
can on va pas pleurer non plus c'est
c'est un moment super agréable dans une
année professionnelle pour ceux qui
travaillent he voilà bien sûr et dans
les longues files d'attente en compagnie
des collègues on partage idées et points
de vue sur les films on narrête pas on
discute de ce qu'on a vu parce qu'on
voit pas tous la même chose on discute
de ce qu'on essaie de voir parce qu'on
verra pas tous la même chose on discute
des différentes comment dirais-je galère
qu'on a et cetera et puis oui on parle
des films forcément voilà c'est c'est
normal un autre exploitant éelinois a
fait le déplacement à Cann Gael Pinot
responsable et programmateur du cinéma
Le Grenier ACL ATT trrape lui aussi
enchaîne les projections toute la
journée et ce n'est pas toujours évident
d'avoir un avis sur un film alors c'est
très difficile de choisir puisqu'on voit
énormément de films on est c'est presque
on est presque gavé de film on les
enchaîne et et ce que ce qu'on ressent
sur le moment c'est pas forcément c'est
pas forcément net parce qu'on les
compare les uns aux autres et c'est pas
très facile par contre c'est il faut les
digérer et avec le recul il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qui reviennent et là
on peut vraiment réfléchir sur les films
et les aimer là si si tu me demandes le
film qui m'a le plus c'est Max j'ai
vraiment beaucoup aimé Mad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Max pour une s c'est pas forcément le
film que je vais le plus
programmer j'ai beaucoup aimé le Woody
all j'ai beaucoup a ce par rapport au
précédent c'est vraiment un film que
j'ai apprécié je programmerai avec grand
plaisir et j'aurais très envie de
montrer à mes
spectateurs g Pino comme lu bean se
fixent des objectif pendant le festival
voir 4 à 5 films par jour qu'il soit de
la sélection officielle ou dans les
sélections parallèles Un Certain Regard
la Semaine de la Critique la Quinzaine
des réalisateurs des invitations qu'il
décroche grâce à une application pour
les exploitants on s'inscrit et là en
fait on a tous les films qu'on a demandé
alors quand ça s'affiche en rouge
évidemment ça veut dire qu'on a pas de
place et quand ça s'affiche en vert ça
veut dire qu'on a une place obtenue il
va y avoir quelques places de distribuer
en plus donc on on va essayer de les on
va essayer de les choper pour aller voir
le film à 11h30 coup de chance pour nos
ivelinois ils viennent de décrocher des
places pour aller voir le dernier film
de Gus vin ça le coup
d'attendre mais il faut se dépêcher le
film commence dans 10 minutes Cann c'est
la fête du cinéma mais c'est également
la
course et nous restons sur la Croisette
encore quelques instants avec ces
ivelinois qui participent au festival
des juniors cette fois-ci et eux aussi
ils profitent de cette grande fête du 7e
s faire découvrir le cinéma au plus
jeune c'est le but du festival des
juniors qui fête cette année son 14e
anniversaire parmi les enfants
scolarisés dans les écoles et collèges
des Mureaux de Verneuil sursène de
vernouiller de Melan et de garganville
seul 10 ont décroché leur billets pour
Cann l'occasion pour eux d'assister à
des projections de côtoyer les stars et
de passer un peu de bon temps sur la
Croisette ils sont comme des stars sur
la Croisette Valentin Marwan Justine
Samia Fatimata kamamila et jya sont les
jurés du festival des juniors des
Mureaux et côté cinéma ils sont presque
incollable la preuve quand on leur
demande qui est Ingrid Bergman l'actrice
dont le visage se trouve sur les
affiches du festival c'est une actrice
une actrice qui a joué dans des films
dans les années 50 60 et s'est marié
avec un un produeur italien comme les
stars les enfants du festival des
juniors sont invités à des cocktails ce
jour-là ils ont rendez-vous dans les
jardins d'un grand hôtel canois pour un
brunch organisé par la région
île-de-fance l'île-de-fance sur la Côte
d'Azur forcément c'est intriguant V
savoir pourquoi il y avait marqué de
France alors qu'on est à
can pour bah en fait c'est parce que ils
ont ils ont installé un stand pour
montrer leurs actions heureusement agès
l'une des accompagnatr sa réponse à tout
la Région
île-de-fance finance des projets Cinéma
sur le territoire et puis il y a pas mal
de films qui sont tournés en
île-de-fance donc la région est
partenaire de de beaucoup de ces
choses-là la région qui est également
partenaire du Festival des juniors un
festival qui existe depuis 14 ans 14 ans
qu'à chaque édition des enfants se voir
récompenser de leurs efforts par un
voyage à can c'est le point d'or on va
dire de tout ce qui s'est passé pendant
l'année puisque ils ont d'abord
travaillé en en participant à un
concours de critique et ils ont été
choisis donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont
bien travaillé ensuite ils ont été le
jury du Festival des juniors en en avril
et ils ont choisi un très beau film Le
Promeneur d'oiseau comme Grand Prix cet
année et puis là on termine l'année avec
ce ce voyage à CAN et ils ne sont pas au
bout de leur surprise alors qu'ils
attendent Jean-Paul Huchon président de
la Région Île-de-France ils aperçoivent
une autre personnalité politique d'abord
on a vu
c'est le premier ministre et ça fait
bizarre c'est étonnant parce que des
fois on voit à la télé et maintenant là
on le voit en réalité petit l'occasion
est trop belle pas question de le
laisser partir sans immortaliser cette
rencontre imprévue manuel Vals encourage
l'action du festival des juniors et
cette découverte du cinéma ça ne peut
être que positif et puis ils le font ici
à CAN qui est le lieu parfait pour vivre
pleinement le le cinéma et comme le
disait il instant jean-pauchon c'est
sans doute
l'art où tout se mélange les émotions le
sens mais aussi la la qualité et donc
pour les enfants j'en doute pas un seul
instant c'est une belle expérience mais
ils nous font aussi vivre leur propre
expérience donc ça peut être utile à
tout le monde une fois remis de leurs
émotions il est temps de repartir
bientôt il faudra retrouver les bands de
l'école en attendant les enfants peuvent
encore savourer ces quelques heures sous
le soleil Jima a une voix magnifique
c'est une artiste et pendant une semaine
Jima a pu toucher du doigt son rêve
allez vasy allez-y les filles faites le
rythme l'adolescente élève de 6e dans un
collège des Mureau se ver bien revenir
un jour pour gravir cette fois-ci les
marches du tapis
rouge moi depuis longtemps je voulais
être comédienne donc ou comédienne et
chanteuse ça donne encore plus envie
quant aux autres il se montre plus que
satisfait comme Samia 10 ans en CM2 au
Mureau on a vu la plage des stars on a
vu des grands building des boutiques on
a fait des des balades en mer on a fait
plein de trucs Valentin 11 ans en CM2 à
Vernouillet a peut-être découvert son
futur métier photographe j'ai pris
beaucoup de photos j'ai on a vu in de la
FR après on a
vu Laurence Ferrari on a vuard bah après
je vais les regarder
après bah après je vais je vais
peut-être les imprimer pour donner à
quelques quelques gens autant de
souvenirs qui resteront à coup sûr
gravés dans leur mémoir et dans leur
cœur on quitte CAN et pour terminer ce
journal retour sur la 24e édition du Mai
des ser les ser municipal de morpa qui
ont ouvert leur portes de nombreuses
associations locales
présentes apprendre à jardiner avec la
lune c'était là l'objectif cette année
de l'opération Mai dessert à mon repas
avoir la main verte ne suffit pas il
faut aussi prendre en compte le cycle
lunaire pour la croissance des cultures
et des plantations la Lune a de gros
influence sur notre environnement
prenons le cas des marais ben c'est
quand même c'est la lune qui déclenche
les marais donc
si une influence sur sur l'eau elle a
forcément une influence sur la partie
terrienne et si vous voulez il est
important de de tenir compte des des
évolutions de la lune quand la lune
descend et bien il faut s'occuper des
végétaux du moins qui ce qui sont sous
terre par contre en lune montante et
bien vous allez à la fois cueillir les
salades vous allez cueillir vos fruits
cette opération a attiré 3600 visiteurs
qui repartent en jardinier mieux avisés
prêts à se faire même le relais de
l'explication des cycles de la lune je
trouve que c'est très très essentiel
c'est que les gens se rendent pas compte
que la Lune voilà afflue sur autant sur
les plantes que sur nos humeurs que sur
les personnes si vous voulez faire
pousser des plante rapidement ou plutôt
plus doucement donc genre les salades
tout le monde le sait faut pas que ça
monte donc en fait on sème la salade sur
une période de lune descendante si vous
voulez des des belles genre des géranium
très longs très grand bien développés
faut plutôt les faire semer en lune
montante et ça permet en fait qu'il se
développe beaucoup plus rapidement la
ville de morepa a cette année décroché
au concours villes et villages fleuis
quatre pétales en attendant de remporter
sa première fleur peut-être l'an
prochain fin de ce journal prochaine
édition mardi à 18h pour vos sorties de
ce long weekend de prolongé pour
certains tout de suite le 78 weekend
avec yolen
[Musique]
Torz